c'est un couloir étroit au cœur de la
maison d'arrêt mais désormais ces murs
ont pris des couleurs 5 détenus sont à
l'oeuvre sous l'oeil du duo d'artistes
et va etc
je vous avoue qu'on a plusieurs moments
pas l'impression d'être en prison parce
que je pense qu'il y a un engouement
puis ils font ça bien aussi on était
surpris par la qualité de travail et
puis l'envie beaucoup ouais ça fait très
bien sur le thème du sport et des Jeux
Olympiques avec la technique du pochoir
notamment ils ont quelques jours
seulement pour créer et réaliser une
fresque les artistes apportent leur
savoir les détenus leur approchent une
vraie complémentarité pour nous c'est
essentiel c'est travailler avec l'autre
et assez fort parce que là ils ont créé
la fresque du début à la fin c'est qui
ont eu l'idée de des personnages ceux
qui les ont choisi ils les ont découpés
ils les ont pas et nous on est juste là
pour leur prendre une technique et
travailler avec eux comme des collègues
en fait on est collègues vu qu'on va
faire le blanc en fait tu vas t'arrêter
là comme ça on sait que le trait il
vient
le street art s'invite régulièrement
derrière ces barreaux cette nouvelle
création mettant scène le breakdance
nouvelle discipline qui intègre les JO
en 2024 dans le quartier des femmes la
réalisation des détenus représente deux
visages connus du basket bérulier Céline
dumer et Isabelle Yakubu avec les trois
participantes qui étaient de la
persévérance l'esprit d'empathie de
collectif et très vite en fait dans
l'histoire bérurière on est allé vers le
choix des des basketteuses le sport
véhicule des valeurs que la culture
représente sur des murs le tout raconte
une aventure vécue à l'intérieur d'une
prison quelques heures d'évasion et de
bonheur